So, we're taking up in November the 24th, 1922, okay?
There are two very interesting things here, and Louisa's going to be talking about Jesus
before Herod, and she's going to look at the effects of the word of Jesus and of the gaze
of Jesus, both of those things, okay?
I was thinking of when my sweet Jesus was presented to Herod, and I said to myself,
"How is it possible that Jesus who is so good did not dare to say a word to him, or
to give him even, we would say, at once?"
Who knows whether that perfidious heart would have converted at the power of his gaze?
And Jesus, making himself seen, told me, "My daughter, his perversity, and the lack
of disposition of his soul," look at that, that's very important.
Everything is according to the dispositions of the soul.
So, a person could go to Mass and receive communion, and if they haven't got the right
dispositions, they might not benefit at all, okay?
The lack of disposition of his soul were such that he did not deserve that I look at him
or even say a word.
I think that's about the worst judgment that Jesus could make of anybody, that the person
didn't deserve either a look or a word.
If I had done it, he would have made himself guiltier because each word or each gaze of
mine are additional bonds which are formed between me and the creature.
Each word is one more union, one more closeness, and as the soul feels looked upon, grace begins
its crafting.
If the gaze or word was sweet and benign, she says how beautiful, penetrating, gentle,
and melodious it was.
How is it not possible to love him?
If then it was a majestic gaze or word blazing with light, she says what majesty, what greatness,
what penetrating light.
Now these comments have been Louisa's comments all along to Jesus' approach to her.
How small I feel, how miserable I am, how much darkness in me before that light so blazing.
You see, we don't see the darkness in ourselves without his light.
That's Psalm 36 verse 9, in your light we see light.
If I wanted to tell you the power, the grace and the good, which my word or gaze brings,
how many books would you not have to write, isn't that amazing?
Now for the power of his word, you have the whole of Psalm 119, the longest Psalm in the
book, hundreds of verses.
You also have Psalm 19.
Psalm 19 says that God has given us two books and verses 1 to 6 is the book of the heavens
and verse 7 to 14 is the scriptures.
Okay.
Now apropos of last Saturday, I want you to put a heading over the next paragraph, disciples
have to become teachers and masters, okay.
That's precisely the school you're in.
This is a very, very important message.
See then how many goods I have done to you in looking at you many times and keeping you
with me in intimate conversations and they've not just been words but complete discourses.
That's for Louisa.
But this you can understand, from this you can understand that the unions between you
and me, the relations, the bonds, the closeness are innumerable.
I acted with you like a teacher who says only a few words to the others who want some direction
from him but spends the entire day with his own disciples, wanting to make of them as
many teachers similar to himself.
So if he's letting you get detailed teaching, then you have to become a teacher yourself.
He speaks at length, he's always over them and first he develops one topic and then he
gives them a similar way to make himself better understood, full stop.
He never leaves them alone for fear that getting distracted they might waste his efforts and
if needed he subtracts hours from his own rest in order to instruct them.
He spares nothing, neither efforts nor strains nor sweat in order to obtain the intent that
his disciples become masters, that's extremely important, you need to color it.
In other words, the Lord doesn't give us this teaching just for our own benefit.
He gives us this teaching so that we ourselves will reach out and we'll teach others as well.
So that's the very reason for the school of spirituality you're actually involved in.
So if you want to put a heading for the next paragraph, you've got to proclaim to others.
You've got to proclaim to others.
But before I give you the proclaim to others, I want to give you Luke 11, 16 to 18 at the
end of the last paragraph, Luke 11, 16 to 18, and 2 Corinthians 4, 5.
So Jesus said, "This is the way I behaved towards you.
I spared nothing.
With others I had just words, but with you discourses long teaching similes at night
during the day at all times.
How many graces have I not given to you?
How much love to the point of not being able to be without you?
It's because of the great design that I have upon you, everybody take note.
This is why I gave you so much.
You then, in all gratitude, would want to keep what I have told you and keep the hidden
inside of yourself and deny me the glory that I would receive in manifesting if you can't
do that."
That's what he's saying, "You can't just keep this to yourself.
If we keep the teaching of the divine will to ourselves, we are doing the Lord an enormous
disservice because there are people out there who will never hear about it unless we tell
them."
He said, "If you keep it hidden within yourself, you would deny me the glory that I would receive
in manifesting it."
What would you say of that disciple who, after his teacher had reached the point of making
him a master through many toils, would want to keep for himself the education that he
had received without imparting it to others?
Would he not be ungrateful and a cause of grief to his teacher?
What would you say of the sun if after I gave it so much light and heat that it would want
to let this light and heat not let it descend upon the earth?
I mean, the very reason why the light and heat is given to the sun is that it would give
it to the earth, so the logic here is that the very reason why this material is given
to you is not just that you yourself grow but that you will pass it on to others.
So this is a very, very important text.
We have to become teachers.
Would you not say to the sun, it's true that you make a good impression, but it's not good
that you keep it to yourself.
So beside that, I want you to put Matthew 28, 20, where Jesus says, "Go into the whole
world and proclaim the gospel to every creature and baptize whole nations, not just individuals."
So it's not good that you keep it to yourself.
The earth, the plants, the generations await your light and your heat.
How much more do the generations of God's children await the light that we have for them?
They want them in order to receive them and the fertility that comes from them.
Why do you want to deprive us of such a great good?
More so, since in giving them to us, you lose nothing yourself.
This is the extremely important thing, that in passing this material on to other people,
you lose nothing.
In fact, you gain.
You acquire more glory and everyone will bless you.
Okay.
I said, "That's the way it is with you, so I want to give you Matthew 5, 14.
Let your light shine so that others may see and give glory to God."
You are even more than the sun.
I have placed in you so much light of truth about my will, that more than the sun, it
would be enough to illuminate everybody and to do more good than the sun itself does
to the earth.
I, myself, and the generations, you need to write that follow because it's understood.
The generations that follow await this light to be unleashed from you while you think of
how to hide it and you almost afflict yourself if a territory of people want to occupy themselves
and putting it out.
No, no, I said it's not good.
I want to give you one Corinthians 9, 16, and Romans 15, 19.
So here we've, it's a wonderful point to finish at Volume 14 with, he says, "Share it
with others, spread the light.
I would hate the Lord to say to me in death.
You didn't tell anybody else.
You didn't share it with somebody else.
You didn't give life to anybody else.
I would be able to take that because I would consider that a complete failure as a disciple."
So I think this message that finishes Volume 14 is one of the high points in this whole
message.
So Louisa said, "I felt I was dying and hearing my sweet Jesus and I felt even guilt here
because during those days, since one of my writings had been withdrawn without achieving
the purpose for which it was released, that is to put it out, I felt great satisfaction.
Oh, how bad I felt in being reproached so severely, interesting.
And wholeheartedly I asked his forgiveness and Jesus to calm me down, bless me, telling
me I forgive you and I bless you, but you don't do it again."
That's called being ticked off, good and proper, okay.
So why would you give this message if you didn't want the whole world to hear it, okay.
And the only people who can tell the whole world is the people who have heard it.
So here you can see that we're involved in a mission.
It's not just a devotion, it's not just a spirituality, it's actually a mission, okay.
So at the beginning of Volume 15, the first message is that the divine word is seed, okay.
And then he'll talk about the divine will, sorry, the divine will is seed and then he
will say that the divine will is the crown of creation and then he will say the tree of
the divine will.
So he's using images that are very powerful in the scriptures, the seed and the tree, okay.
Now the heading for the first reading we have here, which is November the 28th, 1922, is
that the divine will is the beginning, the means and the end of every virtue, there's
no holiness without it.
So Louisa said I was praying, fusing all of myself in the most holy will of God and with
some doubts in my mind concerning all that my sweet Jesus keeps telling me about his
holy will.
And he clasping me to himself with a light, that's your Psalm 36 verse 9 again.
That's infused knowledge which he cast into my mind, he told me, my daughter, my will
is the beginning means and end of every virtue.
Now without the seed of my will and you know the seed is the thing that produces the plant
isn't that right.
Without the seed of my will it cannot be given the name of true virtue.
It is like the seed for the plant, after the sunken roots into the grounds the deeper they
are, the higher the tree becomes which the seed contains.
So first there is the seed, this forms the roots, the roots have the strength to make
the plant sprout from under the earth and as the roots sink into it the branches are
formed which keep growing so high as to form a beautiful crown.
And this will form the glory of the tree which unloading abundant fruits will form
the usefulness and the glory of the one who actually sowed the seed.
So we're talking about the highest spirituality there is and he says if it's not all based
in the divine will as the seed is the source of the plant, forget about it, you're not
in divine will.
The divine will has got to be actually the source of everything.
And so he tells us in the next paragraph that this is the image of his church.
The seed is my will in which the church was born and raised.
But in order for the tree to grow it takes time.
Now remember Luke 811 it's the mustard seed and Matthew 1331 it's the seed becoming the
tree.
It takes time and in order for some trees to give fruit it takes a length of centuries.
This is actually a very important illustration if we just stop for a moment and that is while
it takes some plants just a few months or a year to produce their fruits.
In other cases Jesus says it takes a length of centuries but he's not actually talking
about plants he's talking about us and therefore we have to have enormous understanding and
patience with each other and with ourselves because you don't produce the fruits of divine
will overnight.
And for some people it can be very very very slow it might be seven or eight years later
that I call the penny drops as to what it's all about.
Other people can get it almost the first time you tell them.
We just that souls are very very different to each other but we've got to have enormous
patience and the fact that a person may be slow in responding doesn't mean they won't
produce the fruit.
This is what the Lord is telling us here which I think is very important.
Now watch this the more precious the plant is the longer it takes.
You wouldn't have thought that was the conclusion did you?
You would have thought the conclusion well some of us are a bit slow and we just don't
get the message and Jesus says the exact opposite that if a plant is very precious it's actually
very slow to produce which I think is very interesting.
It's the same with the tree of my will which is the most precious and the most noble and
divine the highest and therefore it took time for it to grow.
That's the two thousand years from the foundation of the church until the revelation to Louisa
for its fruits to be made known and so the church has known the seed because all the
saints have done the will of God haven't they and there's no sanctity without it.
Then she has known the branches or you remember John 15 I am the vine and you are my branches
okay but it's always the same tree that she is around.
Now sorry now that's in the present time she must know the fruits in order to nourish
herself and enjoy them okay and Matthew 725 says you will recognize her by the fruits.
So now is the time at the 21st century that she will know the fruits of this long long
growth of the church and this will be all my glory and my crown as well as all the virtues
of the entire church because the entire church is that vine in every single generation it's
all just one thing and Jesus tells us that the saints in heaven the militant church on
earth and the suffering church in purgatory are all one were not separated were not many
kingdoms so for the rest of this he talks about knowledge of the divine will and the
importance it is to inquire in knowledge now we've just had a message saying that you
must become from disciples you must become teachers well to become teachers you have
to have the knowledge hence the study and that's why it's so important for us to continuously
study the texts now what is the wonder if instead of manifesting the fruits of my will now the
fruits are Galatians 520 love joy peace patience kindness goodness and so on Galatians 520
if instead of manifesting the fruits of my will before I have manifested them to you
after so many centuries okay if the tree was not yet formed how could I have made the
fruits known you can't produce the fruits before the tree is actually developed all things
go like this so he's talking about this divine order in everything and the there's a divine
order in our growth as well and certain things have got to happen within us before other things
can be manifested because there won't be the right environment for them so that the Lord
is very ordered in the way he does things all things go like this if someone is to be made
king the king is not crowned before the kingdom the army and the ministers and the royal palace
are formed he's crowned at the very end and if anyone wanted to crown the king without
forming the kingdom the army etc he'd only be a king of mockery now my will was to be
the crown of everything and the fulfillment of my glory on the part of human creatures
because only in my will can she say I have accomplished everything that's consummatum
est okay I've accomplished everything John 1930 John 1930 and Sam 22 verses 25 to 30
that's the Old Testament version of consummatum est and finding in her accomplished everything
I want not only do I make her know the fruits but I nourish her and I make her reach such
a height of holiness understood because height means height of holiness as to surpass everyone
and this height of holiness is that the divine will is the highest level of spirituality
this is why I love so much and I so much care that the fruits the effects and the immense
goods contained in my will and the great good which the soul receives from it be known and
it can't be known unless somebody is teaching it somebody is revealing it somebody is explaining
it now none of us can explain it at the level that the Lord would like it explained but we
have to do what we can and if they're not known how can they be desired you see if it
doesn't get out that the divine will is the most incredible thing that God has offered
to us nobody's going to want it much less can anyone be nourished by them and if I did
not make known the living in my will what it means the values it contains the crown would
be missing to creation and to virtues and and my work would be a work without a crown he's
talking about a completion it wouldn't be a completed work this then see then how necessary
it is that everything I've told you about my will be manifested and made known he's going
to repeat this message many times as we go on and also the reason why I push you so much
and how I always make you go outside the order of others now outside the order of others
is that the the priests who are guiding Louisa only know about the ordinary spirituality
that's been in the chart for 2000 years they can't push her forward she they can't push
her on Jesus alone can push her on and so he brings her he long before volume 15 he has
brought her to a place where the others can only learn by listening to her because she's
in a completely different space than any other saint okay and so she's way beyond the experience
of anybody else and if these as well as the grace is given to them I make known after
their death in your case instead I allow that what I have told you a bit made known while
you're still living the urgency of that is that with other saints their writings are
only published after their death like Faustina for example but that's all right because it
was within the normal and Christianity parameters okay and so anyone with goodwill can understand
it as you know if you read her stuff but since Louise what was being revealed to Louise it
was outside of what anybody knew the whole thing had to be organized why she was still
a knife and that is because whatever they didn't know she could ask Jesus and get it
clarified Jesus alone could clarify the problems that the church could have so you can see
why he absolutely insisted on the priests being involved from the very beginning so that they
could ask all the questions and you'll find from here on in some of the questions that
Louise asked are definitely not her own I don't think from the Louise that we've got
to know that some of the questions that that are asked are from herself and it'll be nice
if we can guess when they're not her questions it'll be good for you because then you'll
be hearing the dialogue that's going on between the church and the Lord what are you telling
us where is this going what are they you know and so on so that's why it has to be done
while Louise is still living if it's not known it will not be appreciated nor loved which
is absolutely true knowledge will be like manure for the tree which will make the fruits
mature and once they are well matured the human beings will nourish themselves from
them in other words when the divine will mission is well established and the basic knowledge
of it is known people can reach out that they actually wanted and that's happened in Ireland
that more and more people are wanting to actually join the divine will so he said what will
be my contentment and yours so December the 1st 1922 this is volume 15 Jesus did and suffered
everything in the divine will that's the important piece here and then what true reigning means
you see there's a thing in the world outside where they think that if you're the head of
a government or you're a king or you're an emperor that that's raining Jesus will say
absolutely no we've had far too many examples down in history that people who had no control
over themselves were trying to dominate others think of King Herod we've just been reading
about him a man who had absolutely no control over himself becoming a tyrant to try and
control others okay so Luisa said I was thinking about the passion of my sweet Jesus and I felt
those pains so close to me as if he were suffering them at that very moment this is the level
of her union with Jesus that when she's contemplating it she can actually feel it and looking at
me he told me my daughter I suffered all pains in my will now he would he has already explained
before and he will continue to explain that if he didn't do this in the divine will his
passion would not be able to redeem everybody he would be limited to a human thing but in
the divine will then it becomes unlimited and it redeems everybody and I suffered all pains
in my will and as I suffered them they that is the pains opened many paths we would say
my books as ways paths in my will to reach each soul I'm putting soul there and so the
creature had I not suffered in my will which envelopes everything my pains would not have
reached you 20 centuries later can you see what he's saying and everybody else that's
past present and future they would have remained within my own humanity even more because I
suffered them in my will not only did they open many paths in order to reach souls but
they opened as many other paths in order to let them enter into me unite themselves with
those pains see I'm slightly trying to turn this into English is that all right and to
give me each one of them the pains which with their offenses they would give me throughout
the course of all centuries now beside that I want you to put Exodus 17 6 Exodus 17 6
is that moment in the Exodus when Moses was told to strike the rock you remember and that
water would come from the rock and the text says the Lord says I will stand before the
rock and you're told that Moses hesitated why because he realized to reach the rock he
had to strike the Lord okay and the rock represents the rock of our salvation and the water the
waters the grace of salvation and it's precisely what happened on the cross that the Lord himself
the rock of our salvation was struck and the living waters of grace came from him okay and
these living waters have flowed for 21 centuries already so you need to put Ezekiel 36 no is
the 36 37 is the dry bones I think it might be 36 the water flowing from the right hand
side of the temple do you remember it and it flows out into the the Arab and it becomes
a great river it's 36 I think and that's what he's saying here so let me just read it again
this is a long sentence because I suffered the pains in my will not only did they open
many paths in order to reach souls but they opened as many other paths in order to let
them enter into me unite themselves with those pains and give me each one of them that's
each one of us as well the pains which with their offenses they would give me throughout
the course of all centuries that's striking the rock and the water flowing from the rock
and while I was under the storm of blows that's the the scourging my will brought me each
soul to strike me that's why I wanted to give you that thing about striking the rock and
that's why we have my comment at the side is simply a very modern statement me too I
struck him as well okay I'm just using the the language that the me to crowd are using
that's why when we read the passion narrative in holy week that the congregation has got
to shout crucify him they have to because that is in fact our position that that every soul
needed him to die for us and he explains that Louis explains that well in the hours of
the passion and so each soul had to strike me so it was not just the ones who scourged
me but the souls from all times would concur in my barbarous scourging with their offenses
now he admits that it was Barbara's the same with all the other pains my will brought
me everyone so Jesus is making it perfectly plain that we were all there in the passion
every one of us and I think it's it's when we realize more and more deeply that we were
in fact there and that he was paying for my individual sins as distinct from anybody
else's that's what makes the impression we begin to sort of wake up you know and because
some of the people who have become saints have become saints just by realizing he died
from me as well including Paul of Saul of Tarsus he died from a you know that makes
all the difference and my will brought me everyone no one was absent from their own
roll call everyone was present to me no one escaped me this is why my pains were all so
much harder how much more numerous than that which could be seen so I want to give you
Isaiah 53 there they scourged to monthly look no longer human and Louisa described him describes
him like a skinned lamb which of course he was therefore if you want your offerings of
my pains your compassion and reparation your little pains not only to reach me but to follow
the same paths as mine let everything enter into my will in other words if you don't do
them in the divine will they're not really much youth and all generations will receive
their effects isn't that wonderful okay and this not only with my pains but also with
my words because being spoken in my will they reached everyone and in the end of volume
five of Maria Baltorta where she's dealing with the final teachings of Jesus before the
ascension one of the things that the apostles say to him and I think it's wonderful they
say we don't remember anything he said you know it was all kind of a big lump in there
now many people feel that way about Louisa's writings as well that we've gone through all
these volumes and it's all a big clump in there but Jesus said actually it's not a clump in
your soul it's just it's just that your mind can't pick out individual details and he said
if you want the details to come out then you ask the Holy Spirit and he pulls out exactly
what you need so that's like opening a drawer and there's all kinds of stuff in it how am
I going to find what I'm looking for and he said you just get the guidance to pull out
the bit that you want that's very important when you're teaching and helping others okay
so it it's not only with my pains but also with my words because being spoken in my will
they reached everyone and as for example when before I go on I want to give a Jeremiah 31
31 to 34 they'll all be taught by God so as we're reading and studying and meditating
these texts it's actually the Lord that's teaching us nobody else can okay so when pilot
asked me whether I was a king or not that's John 1836 I answered my kingdom is not of
this world poor pilot you would never clue what he was saying for if I were if it were
of this world millions of legions of angels would defend you know poor pilot in the world
and angel was you know and pilots seeing me so poor humiliated and despised was surprised
and he said what you are the king and I with firmness answered him and all those who are
in his position what position is he in leading the world in terrible ignorance happened we
got leaders leading us in terrible ignorance I am king and I have come into the world to
teach the truth and the truth is that it's not positioned watch this now it's not positioned
it's not kingdoms it's not dignities nor the right to command that makes man reign that
a noble hymn that raise him above all on the contrary these things are slavaries and miseries
which make him serve vile passions and unjust men and make him also commit many unjust acts
which disennoble him cast him into the mode and draw the hatred of his subordinates upon
him well so riches are slavaries positions are swords by which many are killed that is
spiritually as well as physically and wounded true reigning is virtue okay I want to give
you Proverbs 10 25 there true reigning is virtue to be stripped of everything which are called
pilot wouldn't have understood to sacrifice oneself for all to submit oneself to all this is true
reigning which binds all that means all souls past present and future and makes one loved by
everyone want to give you Romans 5 17 where he says we reign with Christ okay therefore my kingdom
will have no end and yours is near to perishing so I want to give you Sam 1 4 5 verse 13 Sam 1 4 5
verse 13 I want to give you Isaiah 9 verses 6 to 7 and it must be John 4 3 I'm not completely
sure sometimes I can't read my own writing and Jesus says and in my will I made these words
reach the ear of all those who are in positions of authority look at the power of the divine will
that even though they won't read the scriptures even though they won't listen to the church they
won't listen to anybody the power of the divine will the divine will is in each one of them and
so their consciences will tell them what the Lord has said and let them know the great danger they
are in and to put on guard those who aspire to positions dignities and command isn't that very
clear I think it's wonderful and what Louise is telling us is that you know when when we read
that a little bit about Jesus standing in front of pilot we only read the meager conversation we
don't see what's behind it or that Jesus is trying to reach everybody who is reigning upon the earth
I find that fascinating so December the second 1922 Jesus places three pillars in the soul of
Louisa okay that's very interesting I was feeling very afflicted because of the privation of my
adorable Jesus and if he makes himself seen at all he's all taciturn which of course means just
justice what's going on then this morning he made himself seen in my interior between two pillars
now we do talk about pillars of the church and he's talking about pillars because in the ancient
world when they raised up these big buildings they were all the the the roof of the building
literally was resting on pillars and whenever there was disasters or earthquakes or anything
the only thing that seemed to survive are the pillars and you have that all over the Middle East
you have these pillars still standing okay so the pillars are important and we do have the
expression the pillars of the church don't we and he was forming a third one between these two
and he could lean on one and then on the other so I want to give you something for pillars
Psalm 75 verse 3 and Galatians 2 9 now you might be surprised at Galatians 2 9
but in Galatians 2 9 Paul refers to Peter and the Apostles as those pillars
and he wasn't complementing them either so Jesus wanted to lean on one pillar and then on the other
and also on the pillar in the middle I did want to tell you who the pillars were going to spoil the
text which he was raising surprised I said to him my love and my life when have you put these pillars
in my interior now you are more comfortable so if you are tired you can lean on them and he without
listening to me continue to raise the pillar and kept silent so Louisa kept talking you're supposed
to keep quiet if he's quiet you know but tell me why don't you talk to me she's Italian you know
and you have to talk what is the matter where have I offended you is it perhaps my reluctance
in making known the truths that you tell me that makes you keep silent in order to punish me now
Louisa persists in that opinion that we're in volume 15 she has persisted for 15 volumes he has
told her endlessly that when he doesn't come toward it has nothing to do with any fault on her part
he's told her time out of number and she still persists you've never stuck to your own opinion
that much have you and the thing that's really important to me is considering the place she's in
in our relationship with God that she could still stick to our opinion forgive yourself won't you
yeah because we can find we can find it very difficult to let go of something that you're convinced
about you find very difficult so you tell me she said you tell me that makes you keep silent
oh yeah you tell me it should be what makes you keep silent in order to punish me but I promised
you that I would not do it anymore and remember we remained in peace now no wonder Jesus isn't
answering because this is nonsense isn't it okay and Jesus looking at me and heaving a strong sigh
totally my daughter I'm working I'm enlarging I'm preparing and when I work I don't feel like
talk and dear mind first I want to operate and then I speak another will you wait and give me a
chance it's like you're you're giving a talk and people want to ask questions before you've told
them the message so they're not listening at all at your reluctance as he said I pay no heed
because the power of my will that acts in you is so great that it crushes you if you do not want
what I want okay now I want to give you a few texts for that John 4 34 this is Jesus submitting
to the divine will John 5 17 John 6 28 John 9 4 John 17 4 and you can just put etc because it's a
summary of the John's gospel and also Romans 8 28 okay now because she's she is actually living
in the divine will Jesus has control because it's his will that's actually ruling okay so he says
look I can actually crush you if I want to so much so that after a reluctance of yours you're
forced to run into my arms to tell me Jesus I pray you to make me do what you want you wanted I want
and you do not let me go unless you see that your will and mine are one therefore my silence
is work so that the work I'm doing in you may be more beautiful more secure and more stable now
the Lord can't afford to tell us what he's doing inside of us because human beings interfere with
everything you know that don't you now we say we don't and we say we cooperate but we do in fact
interfere because we are afraid to not be in control it's one of the problems of an adult okay so the
Lord has to work away quietly inside view and not actually tell you what he's doing have you ever
sat down quietly to reflect over the last six months and you realize you've changed in the last six
months but you didn't notice it on any particular day because the Lord had to do it quietly sort of
behind your back in a kind of a hiding mode so he said everything has to be more stable so in
order to do that I put it between two pillars stronger and higher one of these pillars is my
humanity and the other one is my mother so he's telling us there's two pillars we have to lean on
otherwise we won't make the journey okay and he said on which only I can lean
but two supports are not enough for me I need a third one in other words the rest of us need
Luisa as well but if I do not form it from myself how can I have it so Jesus himself has to form
the third pillar Luisa can't do it she doesn't even know about it so here is the necessity for my
work you will lend me the materials that is you give me your will and your consent which are all
your acts done in my will and the more you do the more materials you will lend me and I will
work hard in forming it and then I will rest and speak to you okay so you've heard a number of
things about the the value of acts in the divine will and now you see that he is building a structure
inside of you with these acts okay everything I did and that which my mother did will be connected
together in this third pillar my only purpose that it may be worked with an eternal will which alone
can serve as my support and that this will may be known look at the emphasis again I will put so
much grace into it that it will not only give me rest but it will serve me as a pulpit that's a
place where you proclaim okay it will serve me as a voice to teach in the most attractive
penetrating and convincing manners what it means to live in my will that I may no longer be in the
midst of my children like an exiled one so he's building up the divine will in Luisa so he's calling
it a pillar and from this pillar he's going to be able to teach the rest of us okay and reveal what
he wants for the rest of us but my will and so I won't any longer be like an exiled will but my
will may reign in them on its own throne in other words that the rest of us will begin to live in
the divine will as well therefore let me do let me do okay so he's telling us here that our souls
are the throne of the divine will on earth and it's it's the way Jesus returns to the earth to rule
the earth so afterwards he came back again and he continued to make himself seen in my interior
all intent on working and we would look at each other in silence I raised my eyes and I saw the
head of our Lord placed on the top of one pillar and that of the celestial queen on top of another
both crowned in other words this is their triumph to reign like this in a soul the third pillar
which he was forming was prepared for my head to be put on its top and the crown that was to crown
it came out half from the crown of our Lord and half from the crown of the blessed virgin in other
words nothing from us we're nothingness and uniting together these two halves formed one single crown
I remained amazed and enchanted and my sweet Jesus told me my daughter have you seen how much I have
to work in order to form for myself the third support and how you must hasten to form the materials
in other words give me more acts I need more materials you must hasten to form the material so
to let me work and what height it must reach that that's the summit of holiness okay in order to
accomplish the work of my will in you and what crown must surround your forehead therefore do
not lose a minute of time but let your flight in my will be continuous so I want to give you
revelation 210 revelation 210 one Peter five four one Peter five four and James one 12
that's the crown on your forehead okay
so December the eighth louisa is meditating on the immaculate conception
I write to obey she said and I offer everything to my sweet Jesus uniting myself to the sacrifice
of his obedience now isn't that lovely that she has to do an obedience that's difficult for her
so she unites herself to difficult obedience that he had this is just the clue we need that whatever
we're doing needs to be united to something specific in his life in order to obtain the grace and
the strength to do what he wants and now oh my Jesus give me your holy hand and the light of
your intelligence to write together with me okay I was thinking about the great portent of the
immaculate conception of my queen and celestial mother and in my interior I heard him say
my daughter the immaculate conception of my beloved mother was prodigious and all marvellous
so much so that heaven and earth were astonished and made feast
all three divine persons competed among themselves the father poured out an immense sea of power
and I the son poured out an immense sea infinite sea of wisdom and the holy spirit an immense
sea of eternal love okay so there's three titles for the blessed trinity power wisdom and love
okay and when you fuse in the divine will you can say to the lord I take your power wisdom
and love so that I can pray at your own level and so they all merged into form one single sea
because it's three and one and in the middle of this sea the conception of the virgin was formed
isn't that fantastic so that's Luke 1 48 to 49 she was chosen among the chosen we would take
Klem de la Klem so the divinity administered the substance of this conception and this sea
was not only the center of life of its of this admirable and singular creature
but it remained around her not only to keep her defended from anything which might shadow her
but to give to her at every instant new beauties new graces new power new wisdom new love new
privileges etc because Jesus keeps on saying that for someone living in the divine will the outpouring
of the divinity to that person is continuous okay so her little nature was conceived in the center
of this sea and was formed and grew under the influence of these divine waves so much so that
as soon as this noble and singular creature was formed the divinity did not want to wait as it
usually does with other creatures it wanted her embraces and the return of her love her kisses
and to enjoy her innocent smiles therefore as soon as her conception was formed notice the eye
Jesus has been talking in the third person about the blessed Trinity and then he says
I because he is the Lord I gave her the use of reason the first instant of conception
I mean as they say this is off the richter scale I endowed her with all knowledge
I made her aware of our joys and our sorrows with regard to creation even from the maternal
wound she would come to heaven at the foot of our throne to give us her embraces
and the return of her love on her tender kisses and throwing herself into our arms she would smile
at us with such delight of gratitude and thanksgiving now the thing that's missing from the rest of
us is the gratitude and thanksgiving which such delight of gratitude and thanksgiving as to snatch
our smiles oh how beautiful it was to see this innocent and privileged creature enriched with
all the divine qualities wow coming into our midst all love all trust without fear because
perfect love of course casts out fear and perfect love casting out fear is one john four and it's
verses seven to seventeen I usually only give you verse seven in fact
sin alone is what puts distance between the creator and the creature breaking love dissolving trust
and striking fear that's Isaiah 59 verse two
and Jeremiah 5 25
Isaiah 59 2 and Jeremiah 5 25
so she would come into our midst as queen who with her love given by us would dominate us
and rapture us and put us in feast and capture it yet more love now everything she had came from
them because we have nothing of ourselves and so she's giving back God to God his own love his own
grace his own gratitude everything which is exactly what we're called to in the divine will
and he said we would let her do it enjoying the love that enraptured us and constituting her queen
of heaven and earth now this was what God's intention was for the whole human race if the fall hadn't
happened so we would have been as much at home in heaven as on earth it's amazing heaven and earth
exalted and made feast together with us having their queen after so many centuries that's Romans
8 19 that all of creation groans looking for these children of God Romans 8 19 the sun smiled
with its light and considered itself fortunate in having to serve its queen by giving her light
the heavens the stars and the whole universe smiled with joy and made feast because they were to
delight their queen showing her the harmony of the spheres and of their beauty the plants smiled
which were to nourish their queen and the earth too smiled and felt ennobled in having to provide
the residence for its empress to be trodden by her steps only hell cried that's fantastic isn't it
and felt itself losing strength because of the dominion of this sovereign lady now know the
difference that one makes one is a majority in the kingdom of God and you see we people on earth seem
to think that they could get nowhere unless you have a hundred thousand signatures you know
because that's earthly power and that's totally limited but in spiritual terms one person is enough
and very often to turn the tide of a whole era the lord will use one person he used one Elijah
for example he only needed one mother Teresa Calcutta he only needed one Faustina he only needed one
Louisa that one person truly given to him can turn the tide completely and so I the next paragraph
is act one and the paragraph after that is act two different stages but do you know what was the
first act which this celestial creature did when she found herself before our throne for the first
time now don't forget now she's only a few cells and they say nowadays that that is nothing and
here she is she's going to make reparation for the whole earth see how awfully wrong we are
okay she recognized that all the evil of man had been the split between his will and that of his
creator okay she trembled and with no delay she bound her will to the foot of the throat my throne
without even wanting to know her will and my will bound itself to her and constituted itself the
center of her life so much so that all currents all relations all communications opened between her
and us for the first time since the fall that heaven and earth were open to each other so
the all currents all relations and all communications beside that I wanted to put John 1 51 it's the
latter remember the ladder of communication between heaven and earth and there was no secret that
we did not entrust to her okay so you have Amos 3 7 that the Lord always tells his prophets before
he does anything you have Isaiah 64 10 he will always tell his secrets to the people who are close
to him so since the blessed mother was conceived at the highest level of sanctity therefore there is
no secret that was not given to her this indeed was the most beautiful the greatest and the most
heroic act that she did the very first one which was to lay down her will and never serve her own
will and he tells us that whenever we get to the stage of being able to finally lay down our will
to him that there's nothing else he will ask because that's that's the most heroic thing you can
possibly do now she did it at the very beginning can you imagine how difficult it must have been for
her knowing all of this living in Nazareth knowing everything keep her mouth shut and say nothing it's
when you look at some of the instances in the gospel with this knowledge in the background that
some of her reactions are fascinating one of her reactions is given in Maria Valtorta where Judas
insisted on staying with her for a few days and a terrible damage to Jesus while he was staying
under her roof and her comment to Jesus was that man frightens me what an absolutely measured
comment yeah she just said that man frightens me absolutely everything yeah yeah but that man
frightens me she could read him she knew exactly what he was doing she knew the damage he was doing
to Jesus and everything you know so it's just that this level of knowledge and understanding is also a
huge burden we have the privilege of not knowing what's going on in people's heads do you know what
I mean and not knowing what's going on out there and so you can have some measure of peace but if
you know everything that's going on it's ferocious burden so laying down her own will was the most
heroic act that she did an act which made us as though enraptured and constituted her queen of all
do you see then what it means to bind oneself to my will and to and not know one's own to not know
means to not let your own will be your servant so if we get to that point before we die we'll be
doing well you know because we have a much longer journey to take of course we think we've done it
you know and then you you you discovered that you haven't even remembered the divine will for the
last couple of hours oh because we're way back and I mean we're talking about people who are up in
the stratospheres far as I'm concerned so the second act I just call it act two and was that she
offered herself for any sacrifice for love of us is now something else yeah the third act that's
act three was to render us the honor and glory of the whole of creation which man had taken away
from us by doing his own will and even from the maternal womb she cried for love of us is not
incredible on seeing us offended and she cried with sorrow over guilty man oh how these innocent
tears moved us and hastened the longed for redemption because in Maria Baltorta the Lord
actually does say that because of her redemption was brought forward yeah and this queen dominated us
bound us and snatched infinite graces from us because God is love and to get this incredible
sacrificial love from such a tiny creature would absolutely touch him she made us inclined so
much towards mankind that we could not resist nor did we know how to resist her repeated petitions
but when's came to her so much power and so much influence over the very divinity ah you've
understood it was the power of our will acting in her it's the fact that the same divine will that
operated in the blessed trinity was operating in this little creature so it's it's the same
divine will which while dominating her rendered her the dominator of God himself
okay this is the love God and do what you like of saint Augustine which is vastly misunderstood
and besides how could we resist so innocent a creature Matthew 1810
possessed by the power and the sanctity of our will it would be as though resisting ourselves
we could see our divine qualities in her we could see the reflections of our sanctity the reflections
of the divine ways of our love of our power etc poured over her like waves as well as our will
which was her center drawing all the reflections of our divine qualities and making itself crown
and defense of the divinity dwelling within her if this immaculate virgin had not had the divine
will as the center of her life all the other prerogatives and privileges with which we so enriched
her would have been in comparison an absolute nothing so the greatest gift which the lord is
offering to us as well is the divine will this is what confirmed and preserved her so many privileges
even more it multiplied new ones at every instant because that's the the beatitude of heaven
that they the blessings and the glory is multiplied at every single instant okay so
in the next paragraph he's going to tell us that the divine will remain intact in the blessed virgin
here then is the reason why we constituted her queen of all because when we operate we do it with
reason wisdom and justice she never gave life to her own human will but our will was always
intact in her that's where she's different to all the rest of us including louisa
because louisa had to enter into the divine will later in life okay and louisa had to be released
from the original sin and concupacence all the elements the heavens the sun the earth would have
withdrawn from the power and dominion of this creature all would have cried out in their mute
language we do not want her we are superior to her because we've never withdrawn from your divine
volition so the thing that was extremely important was to have somebody who had never ever gone out
of the divine will so the whole of creation could have said as you created us so are we
so would the sun have cried out of with its light the stars with their glittering the sea with its
waves and everything else on the contrary as soon as they all felt the dominion of this
excelling virgin it's not wonderful language who almost as their sister never wanted to know her
own will but only that of god not only did they make feast but they felt honored to have their queen
and they ran around her to form her courtage and to pay obsequise to her the moon by placing itself
as a footstool under her feet that's revelation 12 one the stars as her crown still revelation 12
one and the sun as a diadem the angels as servants and men as though in waiting okay so the image of
revelation jesus is completely confirming here okay everyone everyone paid her honor and rendered
their obsequise to her there is no honor and glory which cannot be given to our will
whether acting within us in its own center or dwelling in the creature okay i want to give you
one samuel two twenty those who honor me i will honor says the lord one samuel two twenty
what do you know what was the first act which this noble queen did when coming out of the
maternal womb she opened her eyes to the light of this low world now as we go into the higher
volumes earth is called the low world okay um as she was born the angels sang lullabies to the
celestial baby and she remained enraptured her beautiful soul went out of her little body
accompanied by angelic cohorts now this was her first ascension into heaven okay and went around
the heaven and the earth gathering all the love that god had spread throughout the whole of creation
and penetrating into heaven she came to the foot of our throne offered us the return
of the love of all creation and pronounced her first thank you in the name of all now this is the
second time that thanksgiving has been underlined because the human race is identified as ungrateful
okay oh how happy we felt in hearing the thank you of this baby queen
and we confirmed in her all graces now some saints at the last minute of their lives if i can put it
that way were confirmed in grace i say the last minute so that they couldn't sin you know what
mean they're confirmed and was considered by the church the highest gift that god would ever give
to anybody that the person would be confirmed in grace louisa has long since been confirmed in
grace long before you got to volume 14 and here we're told that the blessed virgin is confirmed in
grace and she's only barely born okay we confirmed in her all graces all gifts such as to make her
surpass all other creatures together so there you have her magnific hat all generations will call me
blessed okay then throwing herself into our arms she delighted with us swimming in the sea of all
contentments being embellished with new beauty new light and with new love she pleaded once again
for mankind now you're told this is the second time that she pleaded for the human race praying
us in tears to let the eternal word descend in order to save her brothers now this is incredible
because it's immediately after birth okay can you see that the modern apostasy that is thrown our
blessed mother out they're missing everything that's really sad and so here she's only barely born
when she's interceding for the second person to descend and become incarnate but as she was doing
this our will let her know that she should descend to the earth and immediately she left our content
ments and joys and departed in order to do what to obey okay so to obey I want to give you john 2018
Mary of magda that got up from the feet of the Lord where she wanted to stay forever and she obeyed
him okay and what a powerful magnet our will was dwelling on the earth in this newborn queen
no longer did the earth appear alien to us Matthew 1 24 Matthew 2 14 and 15
so this makes you understand the star of Bethlehem then doesn't it that god wanted to make everybody
find this child we no longer felt I mean Mary's child when the child is born we no longer felt
like striking the earth making use of our justice we had the power of our will which in this innocent
child blocked our arms smiled at us from the earth and turned justice into graces and sweet
smiles so much so that unable to resist this sweet enchantment the internal word hastened his
course that's twice tonight you've heard that he came ahead of time or prodigy of the divine will
to you everything is due through you everything is accomplished we need to really take that on board
everything is accomplished through the divine will
and there's no greater prodigy than my will dwelling in a soul isn't that fantastic
there's no greater prodigy than the divine will dwelling in a soul
we haven't met for a while so I'm going to do another one which is the conception of
the eternal word this is a wonderful piece as well
these pieces are ones that all you can do is meditate on them and let the Lord open it up to you
Louisa said I was thinking about the act in which the eternal word descended from heaven
and was conceived in the womb of the immaculate queen that's john 114
and from within my interior my beloved Jesus put out an arm surrounding my neck and in my interior
told me my beloved daughter if the conception of the celestial mother was prodigious and she was
conceived in the sea which came out of the three divine persons my conception was not in the sea
that came out of us but in the great sea which resided within us our very divinity
so this is a divine conception okay which descended into the virginal womb of this virgin
and I was conceived it's true that it is said that the word was conceived but my celestial father
and the holy spirit were inseparable from me I think that's terribly important as you're reading
the whole gospel and most particularly when you're reading when you're looking at Jesus on the cross
the father and I are one that's john 10 29 and 38 john 10 29 and 38 the father and I are one
the three divine persons cannot be separated it's true that I had the acting role that is that he
was the one who became incarnate but they were concurring because you cannot separate the three
persons in God it's a great mystery that we can't deal with imagine two reflectors each one reflecting
the same subject to the other these subjects are three the one in the middle takes on the operating
that's the second person suffering supplicating role and the other the other two are with it
concur with it and our spectators as well so I could say that one of the two reflectors
was the most holy trinity and the other was my dear mother during the brief course of her life
by living always in my will in her virginal room she prepared for me the little divine
ground you need to underline divine because she was doing doing everything in the divine will
in which I the eternal word was to clothe myself with human flesh since I would never have descended
into a human ground why could he not descend into human ground because it was unworthy and filthy
okay so if the blessed mother had not been prepared the way she was he couldn't have descended
because nothing unholy or unworthy can enter the presence of God she had to be the ark of
the covenant isn't that right and so just put ark there and then you've got lots of references
in the Old Testament that you have in the book of Exodus anyway and so she becomes the ark of the
covenant and the arc of the covenant went before the people so a blessed mother's life had to go
before the whole church okay she's also the the tabernacle in the Exodus as well holding the divine
presence okay and as the trinity was reflected in her I was conceived so while that same trinity
remained in heaven I was conceived in the womb of the noble queen all other things as great noble
sublime and prodigious as they may be all remain behind even the very conception of the virgin
queen there's not one thing neither love nor greatness nor power which can compare to my conception
here it is not about forming a life but about enclosing that life which gives life to all
it's not about expanding but about shrinking myself so that I might be conceived that's Philippians
2 verses 6 to 11 and I also want to give you John 1 4 John 5 26 John 8 12 and John 11 25
so it's about shrinking myself so that I might be conceived and not in the in order to receive
but to give the one who created everything that's Sam 104 30 the one who created everything Sam 104 30
Sam 148 verse 5 Isaiah 41 20
42 5 and you have to add etc because it's all over Isaiah okay the one who created everything
and closing himself within a created and tiny little humanity these are works only of God
knock out the A because that's a wrong translation and and of a God who loves okay it's above all
about love John 15 9 1 John 2 15 1 John 3 1 and 1 John 4 7 and 16 because you'll notice we're
getting here a summary of John's gospel and John's writings okay the one who created everything
in closing himself within a created and tiny little humanity these are works of God and a God
who loves and who at any cost wants to bind the creature with his love in order to be loved
so the whole thing is about love and the whole summary of the 36 volumes is love and divine will
because it's all about the same person but this is nothing yet do you know where all my love
all the power and the wisdom blazed forth now love is the Holy Spirit power is the
Father and wisdom is the Son as soon as the divine power formed this tiny little humanity
so little as to be comparable to the size of a hazelnut isn't that interesting with which all
the members proportioned and formed and the word was conceived in it so I want to give you Sam 2 7
Jeremiah 1 5
Isaiah 49 1
and Galatians 1 15
we're getting such a summary of the scriptures here it's unbelievable
and the word was conceived in it the immensity of my will in closing all creatures past present
and future conceived all the lives of creatures in it Jeremiah 31 3 I've loved you with an everlasting
love so in his conception he conceived all creatures in himself and as my humanity grew
so did they grow within me so even though I appeared to be alone when observed under the
microscope of my will all creatures conceived in me could be seen it happened with me as when one
sees crystal clear waters even though they appear to be clear when observed under a microscope
how many microbes cannot be seen the interesting thing is that doesn't refer to Jesus's time because
they didn't know what a microscope was it refers to Louise's time when microscopes are in use which
is very interesting and it's true I think one of the great joys of teaching chemistry and biology
to children which I've done is to take a little amount of water and put it under a microscope and
let them see how much life is in there and the fascination that they have when they actually see
that the water is living I say this is living water and they say no it's just water I say no no
I got to show you that it's living and just put a drop of it under the microscope they're totally
fascinated then they want to see the rest of it and I said this water is completely full of life
and it doesn't look as if it is it's fascinating so Jesus is saying I look as if I am alone but if
you really could penetrate the reality that was there all creatures were conceived in me
my conception was such and so great that the wheel of eternity now that's going to be talked
about more as we go on remained stunned and ecstatic in seeing the innumerable excesses of my love
there's your Christmas novina okay and all the project is united together the whole mass of the
universe was shaken in seeing the one who gives life to everything shrink reduce himself
and close everything in order to do what to take the lives of all and to make them all be reborn
okay so Philippians 2 again verses 6 to 11 John 1 14
and you've John 3 5 we all have to be born again don't we we all have to be reborn in him
now that's a massive thing it actually requires an enormous amount of time
more than we can actually give it but you hear why the church says through him with him and in him
everything absolutely everything if you're going to Colossians and Ephesians everything was made
through him and for him and he's the head he's absolutely everything so this here what we've just
read is such a summary of John and Ephesians and Colossians that I'm not going there I'm going
to ask you to go there and just read them in the light of this and you'll be fascinated you'll be
amazed okay because what you're getting is a summary so we'll stop there